what is the Galaxy what is the Proto
Galaxy I love that question so the
Galaxy is
um a huge assembly of stars the Milky
Way contains something like 200 to 400
billion stars and most of the material
and the stars are in the disk and when
we look at the night sky
what we see as The Milky Way band on the
sky that is actually the it more the
inner the next inner spiral arm because
we actually live in a spiral this galaxy
is going to make you as a spiral disc
Galaxy
um and we're looking
um actually depends a little bit in the
northern hemisphere we're looking out of
the Galaxy so we're seeing the next
outer spiral arm
and as you can imagine there's only dark
space behind that so we don't see it all
that nice on the sky but if you travel
to South uh to the southern hemisphere
let's say South America you see the make
you and it looks so different on the sky
because that's the next inner spiral arm
and that's backlit by the galactic
center
the galactic center is is a very big
puffy
you know region of gas there's a lot of
star formation that the galactic party
is happening there so it's very bright
and it it makes for this very beautiful
Milky Way on the night sky that we see
so actually if you if you ever get the
chance to experience that I encourage
you to almost like close your eyes while
seeing this and imagining that you're
sitting in this kind of disc in this
pancake and you're just kind of looking
right into it and you can you can really
feel that we're in this 2D disc and then
you can imagine that there's a top and a
bottom and that that we really part of
the Galaxy you can really experience
that we're just not not just lost in
space somewhere but we're really a part
of it and you know knowing a little bit
about the structure of the mikua really
helps do you feel small when you think
about that when you look on the spiral
on the inside of the Milky Way and then
you look out to the outside like how are
we supposed to feel
I I don't know I I don't feel small
necessary necessarily I feel in awe and
I feel I'm a part of it because I can
really feel that I'm a part of it
um I think for many people they think
like oh that's just the planet and then
there's nothing and
that's almost a little bit sad but
that's really not the case right because
there's there's so much more and I
really like to imagine wow I'm I'm
sitting in this big Galactic
Merry-Go-Round and we're going around
the center and I can see the center
above me right and I can almost feel
like we're going going there
um of course we can't really feel that
but the sun does Circle the galactic
center but there's a kind of sadness to
like looking pictures of a nice vacation
place
all we get is that light and old light
is do you feel like sad that we don't
get to travel or you and I will not get
to travel there and maybe humans will
never get to travel there yeah I always
wanted to travel into space and see the
Earth and other things from from up
there they are they're certainly that
but
I don't know it's it's also okay to just
be at our vantage point and and see it
from from here with the sensors with the
telescopes that we have and explore the
possibility yeah